good morning millennials welcome back to
the morning toast and happy
friday friday gotta get down on friday
that's right it's [__] friday
thank god we made it to the end of the
week congratulations pat yourself on the
back friday is amazing i don't know the
only thing better than friday is friday
which we wanted to have today but both
of us just didn't bring the little men
and now it's just the two of us again
sorry we're empty nesters we miss our
boys but at least we have our toys and
they're making noise we in the club
we making noise where them boys at
we need to make a playlist of like songs
about the boys hundred percent we are
the boys in motion we give you our
devotion boys the boys back
the boys are back
they never left no they never leave when
we have pillows here you're never alone
when you're with stress with when you're
with the brass and straw some pillows um
so it's friday it's just a fabulous
feeling so well deserved congratulations
you guys acknowledge the space that
you're in we did it we did it
congratulations class of 2004. we did it
what's up rom
what do you think this is amateur hour
i'm not even dignifying that with the
response no no i just wanted people to
know that like i was saying a movie
quote like in case they didn't know it
like what is she talking about you know
yeah sure so if you didn't acknowledge
it people have been like claudia it's
2022.
you know
yeah fortunately i understand can i tell
you i went to the nicest event last
night
so um ben played in like a three on
three basketball tournament obviously
they lost in the first round but was
that ben who shot the three points yes
look at ben so ben you ben plays in like
rail like all these different leagues
and i never go and he's like i'm so good
i'm like yeah i'm sure you are what's
real uh ramaz alumni intramural league
even though ben didn't go to rome you
expect anyone who listens to the show to
know what no it's like a league it's a
league like it's my high school alumni
league but a lot ben has a lot of
friends who went to my high school so
they let him play okay so he plays in an
alumni league and i think he also plays
in hale
he also plays in hale heschel alumni his
high school um but so this was for uh
charity for big vision do they ever do
rail versus hail they don't but the
winner of rail should play the winner of
hale 100
i'll talk to michael abramson he is the
uh chairman of rail and then it could be
now the new york alumni well it's
premier league janelle the jewish new
york because there are other schools
okay or it would be jail the jewish
alumni intramurally yeah jail whoever
wins gets you
but so ben played a three on three
tournament for big vision which um
ben's really good friend from high
school started this organization with
her mom because they lost someone to
addiction and like it's really just like
the nicest organization they were
talking about last night like so many
people like start their journey in
sobriety but like there's no
socialization in sobriety like i think a
lot of people fall back in because like
your friends are all out partying and
it's like it can be kind of lonely so
they throw like so many events for sober
people like basketball nights bowling
like cool fun things for sober people to
do and it was just like such a nice
event um but ben did lose that's awesome
how can people get involved if they
would like to uh bigvision.nyc big
vision.nyc i think is the website um
so ben's was on a team of three and like
the best player like didn't come he was
like 20 minutes late and missed the
first game they're only 10-minute games
so um it was sad it was um it was sad
but then the second game which didn't
matter because they already lost they
were great i'm like of course you're
good at this one right in the loser
round in the loser round yeah but it was
nice it was nice that is nice i thought
when when max didn't show up i seriously
i thought i was gonna have to play
i was wearing sneakers and they were
like well you need a third i'm like
i'm literally standing right here and so
what happened instead um luch you
remember lucha from high school no one
on his team showed up so he was alone
and he joined that team i feel like you
were you were like dreading them asking
you to play but like you kind of wanted
no i was like
no i i couldn't possibly play me
athletic no
i mean it was only half court thank god
i would never have played full court
like running no
but you were wearing sneakers i was not
a sports bra i would have been not a
sports when i was wearing a sweatshirt i
was already sweating just sitting on the
sidelines like it was it was not gonna
work got it i would have been taken to
the hospital that's really nice it was
so nice and like nice good fun right
family friendly fun then i won um went
home and watched southern charm which i
wasn't gonna watch like when a show has
been off for a while i'm like so like
not it's hard to get back into stuff
unless there's been a lot of press about
a certain thing right so i like
reluctantly put it on and immediately i
was just like back in charleston it was
so good i told you i was watching
regardless of what like it was not
mandatory viewing i just love southern
charm it's one of my favorite shows and
it was so good to be back and have all
these cast members back we will recap at
the end of the show
and i'm so glad to have it back on my
screen me too especially after
interviewing craig yesterday like it was
premium and like having spoken to austin
i'm feeling really good about everyone i
really like everyone um i like everyone
except for like one or two people we'll
get there yeah so should we i guess
without further ado
where are you it's time for the past eye
stories that you need to know before you
wake up and take a bite out of your
morning toast
and today's episode is brought to you by
the new starbucks by energy drink with
caffeine naturally found in coffee fruit
it's energy that's good yeah it's a
beverage that's crafted from caffeine
naturally found in coffee fruit as well
as antioxidant vitamin c it includes
three delicious fruity flavors mango
guava raspberry lime and pineapple
passion fruit it's a refreshing fruit
fruit flavored boost you try saying that
five times a refreshing fruit flavored
boost fruit flavored boost of feel good
energy in a way that only starbucks can
deliver the cans are 12 ounces they have
90 calories and 160 milligrams of
caffeine so if you're looking for a
caffeine damn sun alternative to coffee
whether you don't like coffee like me or
you're just like trying to quit
quit the habit check out starbucks buy
they're so good mango guavas fabulous we
have them in the studio it's a great
thing to drink before the show starbucks
buy energy drinks are available
nationwide online at grocery stores
convenience stores and gas stations
nationwide
great thank you so much for that claudia
it's a pleasure
doing business with you
it's a pleasure doing business with you
it really is always say like how can you
guys work together how can you like be
sisters and work together i'm like how
do you work with strangers how do you
have to like go
i guess we don't really insult like
insult each other but we can talk to we
can talk straight to one another you
know yeah i can't imagine if like i had
an issue with my partner like having to
take time to talk about it no and then
it's like awkward because you're like
talking to a stranger you know yeah and
there's no like no matter even if we had
the worst argument on the planet about
the business like we would never break
up because we're literally bound by
blood like right our family would kill
us right so like when other like when
you think of call her daddy like if they
were sisters never would have happened
yeah but then you think of the jonas
brothers and it's like how could that
happen but that's like hollywood
disgusting venom getting in people's
brains and that's why we don't want to
make it to hollywood no that's what i
live here on the yeah that's why we're
like so located for the sake of our
relationship yeah that's why for sure
it's so important to us you know in
hollywood they call us every day they're
like claudia come out here and we say no
we can't
we wouldn't do that oriented because you
know caroline manzo said blood is
thicker than water she did she was right
it is thicker our first story our
favorite girl is flirting on hot ones
khloe kardashian reveals her biggest
turn on on hot ones with host sean evans
so chloe got a little turned on thursday
during a hot ones interview with host
sean evans the first we feast youtube
series has celebrity guests answer
questions while eating increasingly hot
chicken wings early on in the interview
which was filmed on june 9th according
to a source close to the show okay so
like two weeks ago
he congratulated the star on her new
house and complimented what i have to
say is without hyperbole the most
organized and impressive kinship pantry
i've ever seen in my life she said quote
i don't know if you're flirting with me
but that's the
that's the best flirting you could ever
give me complimenting my pantry okay so
i watch the interview first of all i
have to say you know chloe spoke a lot
this season about how she gets like
terrible anxiety from interviews not
from doing them but like from the
aftermath it's like always something
people taking things out of context and
i always think this when i watch hot
ones like we've seen these people get
interviewed a thousand times this guy
sean asks the most random questions like
he never asks like a classic dumb
question he's so like he doesn't ask
what inspires you no like he's he's
asking the most random things that like
i've literally forgotten about so it's
always like much more insightful than
like a typical late night interview and
it's in-depth it's 22 minutes you
watched it what did he ask her okay he
was asking her a lot about her house a
lot of her about her fitness journey
they talked about her complex cover
which i totally forgot about and she
talked about how that was like such a
big deal for her and it's still like one
of her favorite things she's ever done
because she's she never was like the
sexy girl and like her ass is out on
complex and she was like i love it it's
the best but it really did highlight
like how different she looks because
that was like og chloe when she was
starting her fitness journey yeah um
compared to the chloe we're seeing now
chloe also did make it through every
single one of the chicken wings which
not everyone does which was like a huge
badge of honor wow her makeup she was
hysterically crying choking her makeup
was running down her face oh my god i
think they touched her up because like
she had black streaks coming down and
then like they did
go away like i think she had like a
minute to get touched up um but she was
like a true
girly like she a good sport she did the
whole thing and i really every time i
watch that show i really like that guy
sean like he's so insightful and like
really just doesn't ask questions you
would think of asking i'm like trying to
think of the ones he asked but they were
so [__] random like
a lot about good american
like he's like well is it harder to make
a dress like it was just he was asking
like he doesn't know about clothing he
was asking about her skincare and like
actually was taking notes she's like
he's like i don't do skincare but like
what are like the three things i need
she was like spf
she's like vaseline is a really good
affordable thing she said she slicks
vaseline under her eyes every night to
stop wrinkles
um and she was just being like so the
chloe that we know she was being like
cute and funny and it was an amazing
interview that's so exciting now i need
to watch it and also i just hope this
maybe opens her up to doing more
non-traditional interviews because i do
podcast i do feel like when she does the
the circuit you know the late night talk
shows it's a lot of the same stuff it's
a lot of the same viewers and and they
can be nasty yeah you know here in the
digital space like we
love everyone yeah i mean the digital
space can be particularly nasty too sure
yeah yeah no no you're right and here at
the morning toast like we'll talk about
your pantry all day no like i couldn't
even think of one negative thing to say
about chloe no because everything that
people like say negative about her like
she photoshops her photos like i fully
stand behind her doing that like look
what society did to this girl who was
like literally five pounds overweight
when she was a teenager look what they
made her like she's scarred she's hurt i
take her side on everything no like
people get so bent out of shape about
like photoshop and filters and it's like
sure it's not great
but there's worse things kim there's
people that are dying literally so i if
chloe came on here i wouldn't have one
negative thing to say like i could rack
my brain for it and i wouldn't
nothing nary a thing i think a lot of
times when there's like kardashian
backlash
most of the time i think it's nonsense
sometimes i'm like alright i could see
how you can make that argument for chloe
i don't think i've ever had that
experience like i don't agree with one
piece of negative feedback that she gets
yeah
i have to act my brain but yeah she's a
queen
and it's a great interview wait so the
articles making it seem like they were
flirting did you was there a vibe there
was like something like it wasn't is
this guy single i don't know should we
add them to the list i don't know there
wasn't like a vibe but like they were
talking like a little like flirty yeah
and chloe acknowledged it she was like
look at me like flirting oh my god yeah
like it was it was like me and it wasn't
just the wings i could see her with like
a digital personal personality that's
just what she needs that's just what she
needs and he's 36. perfect she's like
what 38
like around there
she might be around 36 let me see that
would be perfect i don't does it say if
he's married or not it doesn't say he's
like he's like a digital personality who
has like a private life she's 37
perfection perfection okay we ship
ship is coming in yeah because i never
heard of him as a digit i don't i don't
watch hot ones you don't know that you
really like it he um i think he started
the whole thing like it's owned by like
a media company and it was like a web
show
and you know there's a million media
companies that have dumbass web shows
that nobody cares about this one just
took off and started getting like really
huge views amazing guests the first one
i ever saw was jonas brothers which was
hysterical because they were like
answering
really like serious questions like about
nick breaking up the band while they
were vomiting like they were literally
dry heaving it was so good chloe i have
to say even though she made it through
and she was like dying she held her
composure the whole time her posture was
perfect she had a napkin on her lap even
though she had tears streaming down her
eyes and she was coughing sucking on ice
cubes she maintained like a level of
elegance that was
this picture of her she looks unreal she
looked i loved her outfit like she
looked great it was an amazing interview
for chloe and i want to give as much
positive feedback as i can because i
think she's used to doing interviews and
getting exclusively negative feedback
yeah even the comments were like i mean
i don't really like the kardashians but
you have to give chloe credit like for
making it through all the things like
they were they were positive but i hate
that people have to preface like i mean
the kardashians are like idiots but like
at least it wasn't bad yeah like you're
an idiot actually get off your computer
yeah i could never do anything like this
not that anyone's asking me but i
couldn't have you would be the worst no
no literally tabasco is like
they go up to like level it's like 150
out of the spice like barometer i don't
know what it's called and it's like
literally carolina reaper like you take
one bite but it kills you that's me when
i have tabasco yeah i don't actually
i've never had tabasco it reminds me of
real houses in new jersey
yes bill aidan versus joe gorga bill
aiden should go on the show
answer some questions but now it's
gotten so big like it used to be like
kind of niche now it's like a a stop on
the circuit for it's like carpool
karaoke like yeah but
which is good carpool karaoke james
corden said that he recently filmed a
carpool karaoke with like the biggest
name in music right now
so obviously i'm thinking taylor swift
because she's never done it
um i don't think so who do you think i
wouldn't describe taylor swift as the
biggest name in music right now billy
eilish lizzo
i have to think i feel like it's someone
like jack harlow oh yeah you know yeah
speaking of jack harlow as a follow-up
from yesterday uh chris brown released
like his album like who's on it like
there's literally so many people on it
and jack harlow's one of them so
no good not cool
our next story inside lenny kravitz's
island trailer that was also taylor
swift and joe alwyn's love nest right
cause like nobody really cares about his
trailer
but
i did see paparazzi pictures of joe and
taylor in the ocean kissing which is so
not taylor like she evades paparazzi
like it's her business so if they got to
her it was like a total
fluke moment and then
the article was like they're staying in
a trailer by the beach i'm like taylor
swift is staying in a trailer
yeah now it makes sense lenny kravitz's
trailer over the years lenny kraut
kravitz has been living the simple life
in the caribbean and this past weekend
he gave taylor swift and her boyfriend
joe alwyn a taste of it the long time
couple were spotted in the bahamas on
the island of
illusera canoodling
a luthra canoodling in the ocean on
sunday and kravitz's silver airstream
trailer was seen situated in the back i
just can't see taylor i mean i know she
like tours so she spends a lot of time
in like rvs and like tour buses i just
can't see like our queen in a trailer
you know yeah and with your boyfriend
he's like so small and you really get to
know someone the picture i saw it's like
it's like an rv right yeah yeah yeah
it's like on wheels it's really and the
inside looks like a torch yeah but for a
girl who's probably always on tour i
don't know why you would choose to do
this yeah but i'm sure it brought them
closer together also speaking of taylor
do you see she posted this on carolina
today from where the product is yes this
morning i was inundated with the new
luke homes album so i exclusively
listened to that while i got ready for
the show me too and i need like a
personal moment
for a taylor swift clip on instagram
with scenes from the movie are you gonna
see them did you read the book i read
the book it's amazing oh really truly
amazing i don't think you should read
the book that's what i've been told
people are like you're not gonna like it
you're not gonna like it
you would like it if you finished it but
you wouldn't enjoy the experience of
reading it i feel that um so i think
you'll like the movie and i will
definitely see the movie got it okay i
mean now that taylor swift is involved
i'll obviously see it too like that book
is the biggest book since
the bible
it's one of those like it's literally
451 on the sellers list for like 200
weeks that's so crazy so crazy but it is
that good at least you know what else is
crazy how like taylor swift has been
like dominating the tv and movie
industry like
i guess it's because now she's in charge
of the masters that she owns and she's
like wanting to make as much money off
possible but like literally the summary
turned pretty on amazon prime they must
have used 15 taylor swift songs wow
every episode had like one or two now
everyone's associating where the crowd
sing like with taylor swift she's like
becoming like a
mogul
yeah she's like she's giving mobile
energy this week yeah it might be fun to
be able to license your songs to movies
and tv shows that you really like and
that you have full control over like
before i'm sure her label was like
giving it out to you know
oh yeah yeah yeah but also it's like if
you love this movie like you can be a
part of it if you want to even though
you're not an actress technically right
also people really associate like movies
or shows with like a certain song or a
soundtrack and it's like you get to
choose what you want to be a part of
like and i'm sure she reads a lot i'm
sure she read crawdads and probably read
the summer i turned party and was like i
hear my songs for this book yeah and
then she can just make that happen
that's like so cool that's also like
reese witherspoon can like read a book
and be like this should be a movie i'll
make it done
done um and then she could be like i see
this as you know laura dern done no and
then she could be learned oh this is a
lord
um and then she can also be like oh this
character is so fabulous she needs a
stunning actress to play her me
you know i need a job no it's actually
so cool how she can literally like make
herself the biggest movie star in the
world whenever she wants yeah no and she
can just like manifest her favorite
books into
existence and then put herself at the
front center in the way that she sees
fit because there's nothing worse than
your favorite book being turned into a
horrendous movie or tv show with a cast
that you would never choose i've never
seen my favorite book being turned into
but i've seen like book books that i've
liked turn into tvs and movie shows um
obviously the summer i turned pretty
exceeded all of my expectations the
hating game that lucy hale it was like a
fine book and a fine movie it wasn't
like life-changing but i think that's
like it when luckiest girl alive comes
out like that is the pressure i will put
yeah for me that is i was watching this
tick tock went viral of people sharing
their favorite books like a guy on the
street and everyone was giving like it
was much older people so it wasn't like
evelyn hugo but everyone was literally
saying fahrenheit 451
george orwell
the bible like the classics and i was
like where are the young people because
why is nobody saying luckiest girl alive
yeah so that's what you would say i feel
like you would say evelyn hugo
i like them both really equally okay i
have two favorite books
i don't know what my number one favorite
book is i have a lot maybe you haven't
read it yet how exciting is that yeah i
wish
i wish i'm still reading this book i
started two weeks ago and i have to read
the redheads book in like 24 hours is
that run rose run
no we are done with run rose run
actually this month's book is called
girls with bright futures it's about
like i haven't started yet but the
descriptions like the college admissions
process and like some competition that's
what i know joseph rebecca and she got
it from the redheads facebook group so
she said if you don't like it that's
right i took my first recommendation
from the redheads facebook group what
was it okay i'm still reading it right
now but like i was i'm getting like
desperate like i stalked kenzie
elizabeth's book club post till the
bottom i found one great book and then i
was out
so i only was reading once that she gave
five stars so then i went to the
redheads and i was just like reading
comments and i guess i didn't read
enough because i just like chose this
one book because i read the description
and it was like if you love the summer i
turned pretty and you love taylor swift
you will love this book it's literally
taylor swift meets a summary term pretty
it's called the summer of broken rules
and it is so stupid i feel like a
[__] 14 year old like it's actual
like it's not even young adult it's
young kids like i think they call like
middle school like
it's something i probably would have
read like in the seventh grade at camp
yeah and i'm i hate not finishing books
like i hate only if it's like really
terrible and it's not terrible i just
feel dumb every time i watch me what are
you doing [__] relax i'm not 30 i'm 27.
for two more weeks
um that's crazy no shut up shut up
um so yeah i'm just like feeling
embarrassed when i get to the end of the
year and i look over the books that i
read it will be literally uh books for
children toddlers and porn
and that's just a little bit about you
that's just a little bit about me so
taylor swift our humble queen
vacationing in a trailer you'd love to
see it i feel like she went to all these
lengths not to get paparazzi like as she
always does
um and she still ended up getting
paparazzi so i am feeling for her yeah
the trailer wasn't wasn't even effective
but i'm glad she's taking some time for
herself you know 100
normalize taking vacation maybe she's
taking if you can get there maybe she's
taking vacation to prep for something
big coming up yeah like really it's been
a while
since read tv okay but let her live like
you're one of being one of these like
toxic fans who doesn't let their faves
take a break
[__] literally that album came out in
november first of all uh she's the songs
are already written she just needs to
get in the studio and sing them
and like we can't get new music until
we're done with this re-recording so
it's like get it out i'd honestly be
happy if she just dumped them all at
once you know and i know she's like
making a moment because they're all
gonna go number one even if they didn't
go number one the first time i get it
like girl like come on it's 20 22. we
started this journey in 2020
was it 20 i think it was november 2020
when she was officially allowed
yeah but then we had to wait till like
april for
for for fearless and then november it's
just like it's let's go oh okay let's go
okay
our next story is brought to you
a little brought to you by better help
life can be overwhelming and many people
are burned out without even knowing it
symptoms can include lack of motivation
feeling helpless or trapped detachment
fatigue and more we associate burnout
with work but that's not the only case
what any of our roles in life can lead
us to feeling burned out and better help
online therapy wants to remind you to
prioritize yourself talking with someone
can help you figure out what's causing
stress in your life better help is
customized online therapy that offers
video phone and even live chat sessions
with your therapist
so you don't have to see anyone on
camera if you don't want to it's much
more affordable than in-person therapy
and you can be matched with a therapist
in under 48 hours there's no time
there's no bad time to start taking care
of yourself
self-care looks like talking about your
feelings so better help is here and you
could do it from the comfort of your own
home which is so nice and the morning
toast listeners are getting 10 off their
first month at betterhelp.com toast
that's better h-e-l-p dot com slash
toast
thank you our next explosion
youtuber david dobrik is sued for 10
million dollars by former blog squad
member jeff whittick after a near fatal
stunt david dobrik and jeff whitakes
falling out has officially crossed over
into legal territory according to court
documents obtained by e news on june 23
former vlog squad member whittick is
suing david dobrik for 10 million in
damages relating to quote general
negligence and intentional tort
following a near-fatal accident that
occurred in june 2020. in the complaint
filed in la jeff said that due to the
actions of david dobrik he has suffered
from quote wage loss hospital and
medical expenses and loss of earning
capacity
in uh jeff's 2021 youtube docuseries
don't try this at home the youtuber
shared details behind the incident that
he said caused damage to both his face
and skull explaining that he was trying
to make a funny video with a group of
vloggers while they were in utah jeff
said that at one point the group decided
to place an excavator vehicle in a lake
and swing people around from a rope in
his video jeff said that david dobrik
was in the driver's seat of the
excavator when it was his turn to
participate he said quote i tried to
make a goddamn funny video for people
but this is where i made a mistake
i forgot the biggest [__] idiot i
know was driving it almost a year later
david dobrik addressed the incident on
his views video podcast he said quote in
march 2022 david said the jeff thing is
the [__] worst that day is like the
worst the worst thing that's ever
happened to me and i wish i would
[__] do anything to take that day
back and be like i wish it was me up
there and it's a shitty it's an accident
and that's what it was it's an accident
later in the episode he added that at
the end of the day i was the one [__]
driving it it was my video he got hurt
because i was driving that's it and i
[__] know that and like i said any
chance i would get i would take that
back that'll be the biggest regret of my
life my entire life i really hope
there's not a moment that i regret as
much as that one i mean
i've been confused about this jeff david
thing because like
at first when it happened they were like
cool and then jeff was like making
videos and i didn't know if he was like
satire or not he was like talking [__]
about david then they were like spotted
together so i never really knew like if
they were seriously like upset about
this because obviously it's horrible and
it was an accident so like i didn't know
if they were actually like feuding in
real life over this now i guess with
this lawsuit they obviously are there's
a rumor going around on tick tock that
camille vasquez is representing david
dobrik oh wow um
which like if i needed a lawyer right
now i'd call camille up too so i get it
i don't know if there's any truth to
that but that's what people on the
internet think um well i wonder what his
defense will be because he's admitted
like this was my fault i [__] up right
you know so but does just like a lawsuit
like can you be sued for an accident
like is that dumb yeah of course people
slip all the time yeah you know and then
they yeah i guess that's true so like i
think jeff whitake probably has
a pretty good case especially given the
fact that i think before
this incident the dynamics in the vlog
squad which were
created by david like were extremely
toxic where like everyone who was in the
vlog squad except for david was like
these dancing monkeys like doing crazy
things saying crazy things just to get
included and like be a part of the squad
so i think when
if this goes to court and like jeff
whittick's lawyers like paint a picture
of what it was like to be a member of a
vlog squad i don't think it was very fun
like i think it was extremely toxic yeah
and you like create this culture of like
chaos and and recklessness and rewarding
the most reckless right and then
accidents happen obviously and sorry
david dobrik why the [__] are you
driving an excavator you need like a
special license for that right
and just the concept of going to the
middle of
a lake putting an excavator in and
swinging your friends around is so
[__] stupid yeah and this is where
like youtube like prank culture
is so dumb
it's like was it worth it no
no whenever like i see these like unless
you're like a trained professional
like the red bull is always hiring these
like trained not pranksters but like
what's the word like uh stuntmen
stuntmen like to you know jump out of
the helicopter jump out of helicopter
jump up from the earth's surface but
like they're fully trained people who
try
these like amateur youtubers who like
literally take cars and go up mountains
and like flip them it's so stupid and
dangerous like let this be a lesson to
everyone like it's not worth the views
find another niche like
knit i don't know something yeah does
david dobrik do you think has 10 million
dollars
you know it's tough because for a while
like i think he definitely did
he bought this big house and then
he was cancellation central
so
that app he was working on that had like
huge investors from huge venture
capitalists like they cut him out of it
so he's not even a part of it i think a
lot of his revenue went down i don't
think as many people listen to his
podcast listen watch his vlogs so he
definitely has an income he's not like
you know going to be out on the streets
but i don't think he has the money that
we all we're used to like he in his old
videos he's like give away ten thousand
dollars every video right and get a
sponsor to sponsor his video which was
probably like a hundred grand and it was
a couple a week so i don't know where
he's at financially now he's definitely
taking a hit he probably has 10 million
dollars like remember that puzzle too
that i bought yeah i bought two and i
never played them i could literally
still have a hundred thousand dollars
they're the hardest [__] puzzle of
all time the pieces are tiny tiny and
they're all green
that was a good idea also completely
unrelated i think you would like my
coffee today oh would you give it a shot
sure what's in it it's a cold brew with
hazelnut creamer and it's like very
sweet because i just started using a
creamer
delightful i'll send you all the
ingredients
stunning truly stunning oh my gosh so
it's just cold for you guys and i
started using coffee mate creamer i've
used it hazelnut sugar-free and it's
amazing i actually like sometimes it's
too sweet i'm sorry i'm like one stevia
will you ever use coffee mate and not
feel like a 97 year old jewish woman it
is so niche like i know everyone uses
i've never used it before but they they
have it at like synagogue it's like so
jewish even though like i'm sure it's
not everyone uses it but my personal
like memory attaches just like old
jewish women they love it no it's so
good now i get it yeah so i'll make you
one monday i would love to see you i
would love that coffee with harry coffee
with harry okay are you ready for a next
story
some
tv news that makes sense the umansky
family will be starring in a new netflix
reality show about real estate kyle
richards won't be the only member of her
family starring on reality tv for much
longer the real housewives of beverly
hills star's husband mauricio umansky
who owns real estate company the agency
is stead to star in netflix's new real
estate series called buying beverly
hills the series which comes out this
fall follows the agents and clients
within the agency as they navigate the
high-stakes world of luxury real estate
in l.a according to a press release
kyle's daughters farah and alexia who
are also both real estate agents will
star alongside mauricio and the series
is eight 40-minute episodes i think this
is so genius first of all it's a selling
sunset of it all like beautiful homes
and i find selling sunset homes um
because they're all in like west
hollywood to be like kind of boring like
they're all the same they're all look
like prisons like marble no color but
the homes that mauricio sells are like
estates in beverly hills they're so
different like aesthetically i think the
houses are gonna be so sick i love a
family reality show i think like kyle's
family's really made for it like all the
girls they all work together i think
this is like genius this seems like a
no-brainer and i think it's gonna like
take mauricio like business-wise to like
an insane level like what like think of
what netflix did for the oppenheim group
when nobody had ever heard of the
oppenheim group and like a lot of us
have heard of the agency they're already
extremely successful with
offices all over the country in mexico i
think that kyle's about to buy like a
new house like she's
i think this is going to change her life
like yeah and now it's like of course i
think kyle will be on beverly hills for
a very long time but now she has the
netflix connection that's no not only
that if it doesn't work out she can
always be on it's really like a family
show she's on that show it's like lisa
vanderpump and pump rules like she's
still on tv
yeah she doesn't have to deal with the
dynamics of the women i wouldn't be
surprised if like kyle
you know puts up with less than she
usually would have done because she can
always just go join netflix no i didn't
even think of it that way and that must
be like so nice like a safety net like i
could leave the show and still be on the
tv maybe even an even bigger show since
kyle has been a housewife she's always
trying new products hustling like she
did her own show she's done movies she
does her clothing line and like i think
this is obviously the next iteration but
i think this is it you know yes
she you know on all the franchises we
get housewives like with their companies
except we don't really get that on
beverly hills like we've had a few of
course like who could forget the malef
the the vodka rose vanderpump rose
they're like they're kind of above that
like starting skin care businesses but
kyla's like always doing that with her
like fashion shows and it's like
so hopefully we get less of that
honestly yeah i think this is great i
think it's a no-brainer 100
genius and our fifth and final story our
fifth and final story on the fifth and
final day of the week it's always
sad and it's usually a weird story okay
what is it uh the one that got away is a
terrifying new dating show that dredges
up singles past the new netflix show
right on amazon prime the new reality
series the one that got away is a group
of singles sent back to the dating
drawing board the idea is to see if
their sparks end up flying again with
missed connections from their past this
premieres on june 24th on amazon prime
and it's hosted by singer betty who this
sounds like an ad but it's not by the
way betty who i love the host and the
show follows six contestants they each
come face to face with a portal an
entrance to the set that's obscured by
clouds of dry ice and as each wannabe
lover waits nervously water
somebody from their past emerges from
the mist a childhood friend a law school
crush a flirt from a work conference an
old college study buddy i kind of feel
like this is like kind of a great idea i
agree this is not an ad you're right it
does sound like it yeah but i think
amazon is now getting in the game
because netflix has like all these crazy
experiments and they do really well um
so if if they maintain the same level of
like production value it could be good
because i think this is an interesting
concept there's literally like a trope
especially on tick tock when it's like
i'm at my wedding but like my fourth
grade crush shows up bye like you'll
always have like something in your heart
for people and
a lot of people don't explore that right
and also like but sometimes you do and
it can be
rather beautiful and you know sometimes
you have to look to your history
in order to understand your future you
know what this is like
that amazing anna farris movie what's
your number
how so
she goes back with all the guys because
she doesn't want to sleep with more guys
so she goes and sees if there's any
potential with anyone she's dating an
amazing movie is it josh jamelle no it's
chris chris one of the chris's pine
captain america
evans
is it i think it's chris pine no no no
it's evan okay yeah no you're right it's
yeah it's chris evans um it's such a
good movie you guys watch it we've given
so many good movie recommendations this
week yeah you know what we need to start
writing down like these best movies that
are like
underrated
because sometimes i'm looking for a
movie movies what's your number you know
what else goes in that category win a
date with chad hamilton okay chad
hamilton and you know what else goes out
in that category click bad teacher yes
click
no no okay no that's just like nostalgic
movie but okay yeah sorry sure again you
missed it you misunderstood the
assignment
you're such a bad teacher
um okay should we dive into tv recap of
southern charm yes please because you
want to know why he's got money
he's in magazines he's got more honey
than any honeybees
easy as the birds and the bees and the
one two threes by the way
rubble has such iconic i know like you
know
that it's time
also the best days of your life also we
run l.a
the best one like the housewives don't
really they have like
do do do you know they have their jingle
but the like random ass like indie songs
that they choose for the non-housewives
show like what else
there's really not that many yeah
[Music]
so
is brought to you by figs they're on a
mission to make awesome scrubs suited
for the women not the women sorry suited
for the awesome humans working in
healthcare forget boxy itchy cotton
scrubs figs are engineered to be
ridiculously soft and incredibly durable
using their innovative technical comfort
technology figs blends comfort style and
durability into high performance scrubs
that help you perform at your best so
they're functional they're modern scrubs
with a focus on design function and
comfort their proprietary four-way
stretch fabric for a ridiculously soft
feel they're moisture wicking
anti-wrinkle and anti-odor thanks to
silvador anti-microbial technology
and if you don't know where to start
they're super popular core scrubs never
go out of stock or style obviously i'm
not a nurse but i value comfortable
clothing and i do own a pair of figs the
core um scrubs and i just think there's
nothing better than lounging around in
stretchy soft clothing and figs is there
for you so figs believes that awesome
humans in healthcare deserve scrubs that
match head to wherefigs.com and use code
toast to get 15 off your first order
that's w-e-a-r-f-i-g-s
com code toast for that 15 off
um southern charm
so i don't know if it's because like
craig was just here but like the way i
stand craig and the way i'm like proud
of him for standing up for himself and
it's like pissing me off that like
austin and craig austin and shep are
flipping here's what's going on like
craig was treated like [__] for so many
years and he like dug himself out of
this like hole he was in
made himself a successful business
successful lawyer successful
relationship and realized that the
people in his life who were bringing him
down and keeping him down are not really
his friends so he decided like for his
you know
own success and own mental health like
to step away from those friendships and
craig chef and austin are twisting it
like you got successful and you forgot
who you were like that's not what it is
like no no it's so lame and it's a lie
he got successful and realized he
deserved better right and that these
people weren't here for him and they did
not serve him no and maybe the reason
why he didn't get his act together for
so long was because he was being treated
like a kid yeah no and it just
you could maybe watch a show and be like
oh maybe he did leave shep behind with
his success then we cut to shep calling
his dog craig and we're like oh no never
mind now we and now i remember no and
then you cut to his interview shep's
confessional confessional like why would
i go to a retail store that sells
pillows like that's first of all so rude
they sell more than pillows too a
pringle was just there like to support
your friend right you don't go to a
store yeah so it's it's honestly really
clear even though i think shep is doing
everything in his power to make it seem
like he's not jealous like he's so
jealous yeah and like because shep is
coming off of like not a great couple
years in terms of seasons of housewives
uh housewives seasons of southern charm
and also as craig was telling us like he
hasn't even worse season this year so
like
it's like the roles have reversed shep
had a craig had a bad couple seasons and
now shep is having them craig had a bad
couple seasons personally but the
audience has always liked loved him and
he's never done anything to hurt like us
you know he's just like was in a hole
himself and this whole dynamic and after
talking to craig
i'm glad we spoke to him because i
probably would have put more stock into
like they did anything uh and because
it's like
obviously craig and paige are everything
she looked
incredible and like it's a really hard
room to walk into yeah no they're
everything i love them so much but like
i once felt that way about craig and
naomi i know and it worked for paige i
would still feel that way and just to
see like that there is some sort of
glimmer not that there is any hope but
that like there kind of was i thought
these two would never speak again like a
strange like when it was bad it was
really bad and like the fact that like
the way that naomi talks about him like
she was the he was the biggest love she
ever had it's just so nostalgic i know
and like i want to give in to those
feelings but i've i ride so hard for
paige yeah yeah yeah of course i hate
that they're like making it a thing and
i will say what i [__] love about
craig is like he has no secrets from
paige like paige knows about natalie and
knows about naomi and the fact that
austin went over to paige in like spite
and was like oh do you know that craig
[__] natalie first of all yeah she
does know that and second of all you're
such a shitty friend and then he's
surprised that craig never told him that
he hooked up with naomi and vegas like
obviously you're horrible horrible i
like i'm hating austin and craig i know
i mean austin and chap i keep saying me
too but i'm the more i hear about paige
and craig's relationship like the more i
love
and then there's the whole naomi and
catherine thing so
that's surprising because remember it's
so crazy how much the show has been
through and like if you guys have been
watching from the beginning like it used
to be so twisted and you know who i was
thinking about while i was watching last
night that piece of [__] jd remember of
course awful awful man and remember when
it was like the show was really like a
boys club yeah and they were so
mean mean especially to catherine but
then there was one season where the
girls started coming out of the woodwork
and they they linked up they all like
got together before they went over to
shep's house one night and it was naomi
it was katherine and it was like danny
and it was so nice to see them come
together and that's really when the tide
started to turn so to see naomi and
catherine at odds just really hurt my
heart no it's definitely sad but like
if i was friends with cam i would be mad
at catherine too yeah like what she did
first of all baseless accusation
cameron's not even on the show anymore
it was [__] up and i think naomi's
being a good friend by saying that right
catherine is unwell like first of all
what was going on with her lipstick her
whole bottom half of her face was ready
i know because she was peeling from her
retinol she said oh but that was her
lipstick like
getting all the i was like someone
she was giving darinda i think her
makeup was falling off because her face
was flaking from retinol got it and the
way she was talking to her boyfriend was
so disgusting
like i was shook like i'm going back to
my house [__] you literally live there
together like right i was just thinking
do you have another house no like she
was just like you're not welcome like
because also the way that she even
described she was like we moved in
together and we decorated our place
together and i was like waiting for a
buck because that's just it sounded like
half a sentence yeah because remember
last season she was living in a house
and she was driving a bentley and
everyone was like she's spending above
her means like what happened to the
house no but the apartment's nice and
she was fixing up it was her grandma's
house
[Music]
every season southern charm people are
in new houses especially catherine yeah
and uh naomi's house i think it's her
parents house oh okay because that's a
big house it looks like also that girl
olivia's house who was living with her
parents yes yes it's obviously a really
wealthy part of charleston uh need one
of those houses on the water like so
sickening
olivia's house was so nice and they
always bedroom like that little sitting
area i was shook yeah it has to be her
parents house yeah now that i think
about it
yeah it was so nice it was really really
nice so what were we just saying okay
catherine and naomi so catherine is just
insane and she was so drunk and like
naomi kept her composure because there's
literally no sense in arguing with
someone who's in a state of mind like
that it's fruitless yeah no when she
gets so indignant and like when she
leaves and it's just like
there's no talking to her no she was
like naomi you think you're better than
me and she actually never said that but
by the way you're acting like i would
say naomi is better than you in this
moment yeah it was a low moment so you
were like literally you were creating
it was a self-self-fulfilling
thank you i couldn't create like think
of the phrase um and then madison showed
up looking so sickening i literally
forgot how stunning she was um and
austin was just giving off giving off
losery vibes and i felt for olivia she's
like literally why am i here yeah no and
austin is always just like no i finally
opened my eyes i saw the light and you
know it's over and
if that were true like he wouldn't care
that madison is in the room he's so
obsessed with her and i just love her i
love her and i love the way she like
makes him so angry yeah like just her
mere presence like infuriates him i love
it someone said something to her and she
had the best comeback and i was just
like she's just that girl she also like
doesn't give a [__] no and her talking
to page was like everything i'm like yes
queen energy staying out of things like
i really love the women of southern
charm so do i much more than the men
yeah except craig is like my favorite oh
of course and the thing is i actually do
like the men
most of the time just on the show they
just are terrible men and when they're
like in charleston and like their
element they're just like man children
yeah and that's what the whole show has
been like all i mean it used to be
thomas but now shep is 42. i know when
they were talking about their ages i'm
like you're literally like too old to be
playing these games 42. like and you're
still like ragging on your friend who's
like successful and you're still you
know
not wanting to put labels on things with
this amazing girl it's such a joke yeah
i have to say i have so much love in my
heart for pringle like the way i still
ship him in madison like you know two
single parents like i'm obsessed um and
that scene where they went to the store
was so nice because first of all that's
store
store it's a store and it's like in
places like
on a main street you know there are
stores like that that just like sell
pillows and things like pottery barn why
not craig's store it's so well done it's
so nice and it's not just like here's
the southern charm spectacle come take a
look it's like no the in touristy towns
there's always like things stores that
have you know charleston merch whatever
and like why not craig totally i thought
i was so impressed like really so
impressive like so proud of craig
um and i just love pringle like i feel
like he's kind of irrelevant but like i
love him you know when i ship him with
every cast member what about pringle and
naomi no i actually think i saw
something between pringle and catherine
no the imperial and catherine kissed
last season oh did they yeah they both
have kids like and pringle and madison
even though she has not with that guy
right now right caleb
no they broke up in real life right
i mean if someone spoke to me like that
i would break up with them the next day
like are you i don't care how [__] up
you are like [__] off and also caleb was
a ravenel
no but he spoke when he was talking to
um vanita he was not like
bad like he was very balanced yes he
like he's a good he's taking up for
catherine but he was also like extremely
calm and like that's what catherine
needs like he's a good compliment to her
chaotic energy um and i think he like
grounds her in a sense but she's a
little out of control
yeah
and the silk scarf didn't look good on
the white jacket i wish he wore a black
jacket it would look so much better is
bothering me the whole time because it
was like an ivory jacket and a stark
white scarf and like it was just
bothering me a lot the whole affair and
like all the silly
clowns progressing to the circus
circus and like to just like be in a big
room where everyone's just like filming
and and at one point she's like the
music's really good and we're like what
music like yeah you can't hear anything
it was a silly party a lot that happens
a lot on reality shows yeah because they
can't play music you can't play music
they can only invite each other and they
have to be dressed up and it's just like
weird this is a weird conference um also
really sad about michael
i hope patricia is like taking care of
his medical bills i assume she is but
that was really sad that was really sad
and that was really gross with all the
dogs ugh that's always happening in
housewife like ramona's dog it's
disgusting train your dogs like i
i need to look at the [__] like it's
disgusting right why do they show it
they do it on every [__] reality show
it's disgusting gross okay so now we
know patricia's house smells like dog
[__] and vodka that was sick
sick um so it's a good opener i think
there's a lot to come
team craig for life we're at dawn yeah
team everyone yeah but mostly craig yeah
but also what i don't understand is why
leva who's also really good friends with
cameron like doesn't have the same issue
with catherine that leva is a [__]
starter that's exactly what i was going
to say thank you it was my final point
the way that like naomi had to be like
don't make it weird when i talked to
catherine and she was like no i won't so
like naomi knows that about her and
craig too and with craig then
when catherine and naomi started going
at it like level was the one who was
like mediating and then bounced like i
think she's a [__] starter yeah
i'm excited i like her so i'm excited to
see what she brings what kind of [__]
she starts
[Laughter]
um so that was southern charm recap that
was your final show of the week we are
back in studio on monday of next week we
have shows monday tuesday wednesday
thursday next week and then it's july
4th so we're off friday and monday for
the long weekend we hope you guys can
get some time off too relax
and thank you for an amazing week and
thank you so much for listening to the
morning toast monday morning show what
do you do and our new episode of
breaking bread is on spotify today in
the app store in the app store on
spotify today you can listen to it on
demand whenever so if you're craving a
little more toast anyway and you've got
the live show you already got through
all the patreon episodes because there's
so many and they're so premium head over
and listen to breaking bread it was so
much fun thank you guys so much for
listening to the morning toast the
millennial morning show where we deliver
the fast life stories that you need to
know every monday through friday on
youtube so if you're listening to this
on youtube make sure to subscribe and
give this video a thumbs up we're also
available as a podcast and we're
podcasts can be found spotify itunes
stitch or public video i have already
stopped all the places wait listen back
and find us more just like faster view
better beautiful standings more viewer
have an amazing friday and great weekend
and we'll see you guys on monday bye
you